ok voilà
salut françois tu t'amuses bien oui je
suis très occupé bonjour je ne vous
avais pas vu en arrivant je me dépêche
ouvrir le kiosque parce qu'il fait une
telle chaleur dans l'île que les joueurs
de valence avoir face aux eau au joli
francois monier
qu'est-ce qui se passe et quand il se
passe quelque chose d'incroyable à
l'autre bout de l'île
j'espère que c'est pas grave non non non
non mais il y à un loup un vrai loup qui
vient de se marier avec une dame fort de
ça alors j'ai jamais entendu parler d'un
mariage entre deux espèces aussi
différents que c'est incroyable vous
savez ce qu'ils vont avoir comme enfants
manon pourquoi eh bien ils vont avoir
les bébés loufoques ont été mis en
examen
tu nous as bien fait marcher avec ton
histoire stupide je vous ai bien nul
j'ai une idée
nous allons faire une comptine avec
toute une famille d'animaux vous êtes
d'accord
les enfants vite vite ce n'est pas dans
le jeu cela se fit en face de moi un
tout le monde est là je ne veux vraiment
pas aller
voilà comment ça va se passer on va
passer en revue toute une famille
d'animaux on commence par le fatah vous
me donnez un nom d'animal qui se termine
par a
après la maman qui se termine par en est
ainsi de suite
vous avez compris chez vous par exemple
je donne un petit exemple qui est le
papa le papa c'est un veau à nouveau là
où on y va et bien qui est le papa
julie joly prend ton bloc écrite ou un
qui est le papa
1-1 quoi tu dis un panda tramway qui est
la maman inquiète la maman ça rime par
la sarine sort quasi mis en chantier la
maman un faisan voilà la faisons hélène
hélène trouve tout jusqu'à présent alors
qui est le garçon 1 à lyon frédéric à
lyon sait très bien qui est la grande
fille à quoi des 10 il ventait renom ça
rime pas un la grande fille une indigne
enfin la grande si c'est une anguille
qui est la cadette qui est la cadette
nous chercher
neil wales qui est la cadette une
alouette ça marche mais la cadette alors
après on continue la famille le grand
père qui est le grand père est une
réponse à ses fans
le grand-père un lampadaire
casimir lotader offre à nos enfants de
nos marins une cause tempère un grand
mère ton père ça marche c'est donc une
prothèse une panthère sommes évidemment
qui est la grand-mère qui est la
grand-mère à oui il nous faut changer
haha d'un petit meneur chez la
grand-mère elle vient par exemple moi je
lui dois tout sur ma mère
bravo stéphane un dromadaire la grand
mère un dromadaire annonce par exemple
le cousin qui est le cousin de cousins
la première ça marche tu as vu quels
souvenirs c'était ça marche formidable
d'aujourd'hui alors après le cousin et
bien la cuisine évidemment qui est la
cousine une lapine d'accord oui c'est
bon mais enfin après le lapin la lapine
enfin c'est beau quand même un une aux
yvelines une cible un merveilleux ça
marque une vie bling et bien je crois
qu'on a on a une belle famille l'a déjà
qu'en pensez vous vous en avez trouvez
vous il est vrai ce qu'on va faire on va
tout relire montre moi ça julie a on va
voir ce qu'on a fait beau ou mais ça m'a
pas l'air mal du tout hein
écoutez qui est le papa saint gobain qui
est la maman un petit cas immo qui est
le garçon c'est un grand lyon qui est la
grande fille [ __ ] anguilles qui est la
cadette ainsi la highway qui éclaire une
jolie panthères dit l'armée jeu trauma
des incendies et le limousin un affreux
la présidence a très bien marché
tu sais moi les le texte j'ai pas fais
très attention mais le rythme est
formidable padam padam padam padam padam
gelé bien danser à un continent au quasi
me
[Musique]